تذكر أنهم
قصفوا المفاعل النووي العراقي في
عام 1981 وضربوا بانتظام أهدافًا إيرانية
في سوريا ،
لكن حتى بعض الطيارين القتاليين الإسرائيليين الموقرين
يطلقون الآن طلقات تحذيرية مع
جنود الاحتياط من سرب واحد يتخطون
دورة تدريبية ويقترحون أنهم قد
لا يستجيبون لنداء الواجب إذا كانت
الحكومة  رامز من خلال
الإصلاح القضائي في هذا البلد ، وهو
أمر كبير للغاية ، حيث أن مجرد وجود إسرائيل
يعتمد على سلاح الجو الإسرائيلي ببساطة
لأن نيري أركوني كان طيارًا إسرائيليًا مقاتلًا
لمدة 30 عامًا ، فهو أيضًا محامٍ
يحذر من أنه إذا
استمرت الحكومة في الخطط  لتحييد
المحكمة العليا وإعطاء نفسها
سلطات كاسحة ، قد تكون البلاد في ورطة
لأننا نتحدث فقط عن بضع
مئات من الأشخاص ،
إذا فقدت البعض منهم ، فإن
وجود رئيس بلدية إسرائيل
يتدهور بشكل أساسي
وهذا هو السبب في أن الحكومة وجميع  يشعر
الناس في إسرائيل بقلق بالغ
إزاء احتجاج
الطيارين الإسرائيليين على الطائرات المقاتلة ، حيث قال
وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي الذي رآه يلتقي
بقادة الاحتياط من
الخدمات المشتركة يوم الثلاثاء إنه يستمع
لأسابيع من الاحتجاجات الثلاثة في إسرائيل التي
فشلت حتى الآن في إقناع
الحكومة حتى بوقفها مؤقتًا.
يمكن لخطط الإصلاح القضائي هذا التحذير من
بعض طياري سلاح الجو الإسرائيلي ، وهم
نفس الأشخاص الذين تتمثل مهمتهم في الدفاع عن
وجود إسرائيل ، فهل من الممكن أن يحالفهم
المزيد من الحظ في ضوء الوضع الحالي ،
أعتقد هذا المحلل أنهم
سيفكرون في ما نراه الآن من
أه من الطيارين المقاتلين هي
لعبة فاتورة جديدة تمامًا إنها تصعيد
للاحتجاج تأتي جنبًا إلى جنب مع
إجراءات تصعيد أخرى ويبدو
أنها كرة ثلجية
تكتسب المزيد والمزيد من الزخم وأعتقد
أنها ستجلب الحكومة إلى  الجدول
على الأرض على الرغم من أن القليل على ما يبدو
يغير الإصلاح القضائي للحكومة لا
يزال على المسار الصحيح ويوم آخر
من الاحتجاجات الجماهيرية ربما مع عدد قليل من
الطيارين من بين الحشد من المقرر يوم
الخميس